[Music]
now about three out of four executives
cite technology as critical for their
sustainability efforts
the next question then arises how can
organizations measure and minimize
carbon pollution from it operations
which is also known as greenhouse gas
emissions well let's explore how to do
so on google cloud
first let's begin at the source aka the
energy that flows through data centers
and powers the compute resources
organizations use
electricity was historically sourced by
burning fossil fuels but this has been
changing over the last decade thanks to
huge investments and accessibility in
renewable and non-carbon producing
energy like solar wind geothermal etc
since 2017
google has matched a hundred percent of
its global energy use by purchasing
renewable energy and has mitigated the
annual carbon footprint of our customers
digital applications and infrastructure
we are also currently working on the
ambitious goal of operating a hundred
percent of the time on carbon free
energy by 2030
this means we will match our energy
demand for every hour of every day in
every region where we operate with
carbon-free energy supply
for now it's important for each of us to
reduce our cloud-carbon emissions by
making decisions on the time of day and
the regions that power our resources and
so for starters it's incredibly helpful
to understand where your electricity
comes from by using online tools like
the ones our partner electricity map has
made available for free
the next thing is to calculate your
organization's specific it-carbon
emissions
and for this google cloud customers can
leverage the out-of-the-box carbon
footprint dashboard in the console which
is viewable by folks with billing admin
rights
it includes accurate charts and tables
on total emissions by project by month
by product by region etc
this same functionality will also be
available for workspace customers early
next year with carbon footprint you can
also optionally export the data to
bigquery to perform custom analytics and
visualizations and use this data for
sustainability reporting requirements on
scope 3 greenhouse gases auditing
and as a friendly reminder there are
three emission categories at this time
called scope 1 2 and 3 to help
enterprises measure their carbon impact
and so scope 1 and 2 relate to emissions
specifically controlled by an
organization
scope 3 are an organization's indirect
emissions such as their suppliers
activities or their consumers product
usage or effects from transportation and
waste disposal to just name a few
now once empowered with our carbon data
let's take action by diving into some
strategies for reducing carbon emissions
in your google cloud infrastructure
for starters i'm happy to share that the
easiest and most impactful emissions
reduction can come from selecting
regions powered by cleaner energy in
your cloud projects
google introduced a metric called the
carbon-free energy percent or cfe to
empower users to select regions with
higher cfe percentages because they
produce fewer carbon emissions
in many of google cloud's products when
choosing a region there's also a
friendly low co2 icon in the cloud
console
this icon is also annotated in the
locations page of the documentation for
different products
now if you are looking for proactive
advice on what regions to use
there's also the fantastic region picker
tool that helps you compare priorities
around lowering emissions versus pricing
versus latency
for example you can learn that by moving
a workload from london to finland you
can increase the carbon free energy
percent by 23
and lower the price by 14
i really recommend you check it out when
you have a chance
and if your organization provides users
with a choice to select cloud regions
you can furthermore set organizational
policies to restrict locations to low
carbon intensive regions using low
carbon mode
or you can allow or deny specific
regions in the policy value box when
configuring the resource location
restriction
you do this by entering the in prefix
and then a specific string for one or
multiple low carbon locations
the next recommendation is to avoid
resources from running 24 hours a day
especially for development and testing
and so for example by shifting resources
to operate 10 hours a day during five
work days a week instead
you can reduce your footprint by 70
which is an impactful and cost-saving
move
and on the same topic around scheduling
programming workloads to run during the
day when there's clean energy available
like solar or wind is also very powerful
for example checking the energy mix in
the uk on electricity map at 7 pm shows
its 284 grams of carbon dioxide
equivalent per kilowatt hour of
electricity
however
executing that same workload earlier in
the day such as 1 pm can be 200
and so by shifting workloads that may
have operated at night to run earlier
like at 1 pm can reduce carbon emissions
by up to 29 percent
and of course in addition to
intentionally shortening resource
schedules you can also proactively
delete unused vms optimize vm shapes as
well as shut down inactive projects
this is where the active assist tool
really shines as it proactively suggests
carbon reducing configurations along
with other cost performance and security
friendly actions
this is thanks to machine learning
there's also several low carbon
architecture designs you can improve
here's just a couple
for example by using managed serverless
products you can leverage their
separation in storage and compute
resources enabling to use the same
storage space while auto scaling vms up
or down based on traffic
this also prevents incurring compute or
storage costs from idle resources
and by also refactoring monolithic
applications into bite-size
microservices you can gain many
efficiency benefits this is because
microservices operate as self-contained
modular functions that have less
dependencies
they are easier to maintain and debug
and offer more granular control over
resource scaling and less tests
and so in summary wherever you are on
your sustainability journey you have
tools you can use in google cloud such
as carbon footprint regent picker or
active assist that are out of the box
which i have linked in this video's
description along with other helpful
strategies
and friends if there's one main thing to
remember the best way to reduce your
day-to-day carbon footprint is by
picking the lowest carbon intensive
regions
for more information and best practices
please check out
cloud.google.com forward slash carbon
footprint
cheers
[Music]
you